right yeah so ipagamine hypergamy is
that women want to date are constantly
trying to date up no no no no wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait women are
constantly trying to date up they're
trying to get trying to get the best
deal that they can get men men will get
a deal and be like you know what I'm
actually quite happy with this and hang
on let me finish men will get a deal
they will get a woman who's a six out of
ten
she takes all the boxes and they will
Coast for the rest of their life wait
wait wait
so women are always looking for that
level up right which is why which is why
if I was to ask all of you women here
right now the types of men that you want
you would probably list a man in the top
20 of men right but if you're listening
to Madison the top 20 of men what's
gonna happen is what if a man comes up
who's in the top 15 whatever man that
comes in the top ten percent
you just show me you just showed me his
picture
that's not he's talking about vinegars
yeah we don't have the same time but but
it doesn't not go down to like back for
example there's a traditional way of a
man needing to provide for a woman and
you know I'm saying are positions in
life even through traditional culture
does that not work fools to you when you
exactly no I mean because when he's
talking about women trying to get the
highest chaos
I'm trying to go like from hair to hair
career-wise money-wise home family for
example so exactly that's what you boys
I'll tell you why you you take Kim
Kardashian for for an example right Kim
Kardashian started out with Ray J right
yeah then she went to Reggie Miller he
was an NFL football player right and
then there was an I think there was
another NFL football player right and
then she found Kanye but she went down
but Kanye was the Pinnacle of Kim
Kardashian's
um the man that she could find right so
what she
she started to breed with because in her
in her heart and her mind she was like
this is Top This is top level so she's
she's now got four children for Kanye
right then wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait let's wait wait yeah she's got
four children for Kanye right she felt
like she found the Pinnacle he's a
billionaire she's a multi-millionaire
yeah she felt like that was her level
after that she divorced Kanye where's
she gone to
do you know what that's true Pete
Davidson right and you know why because
after having four children
right so after so after Kanye West from
here on out it's downhill for Kim
Kardashian because she's got four
children
let's not cat though as girls like how
of course you want to hurt of course
wait of course you want to reproduce
with the best guy you can no yeah
the way I see it is that as girls we
always look for the best because
we want them like we don't I don't know
I'm speaking from personal experience
anyways and
if I meet a guy that's got everything I
want I'm not cheating on him I'm not
looking at other guys I'm not worried
you know what I mean but if you see if
you're dating someone and you see like
things that are missing in that person
automatically your eyes gonna Wonder
guys they can have a 10 10 girl
everything lay down for them whatever
and they're still cheap
I have a question for you would you
rather have a guy that had everything
you wanted but he cheated from time to
time but you were the main chick or a
guy let's say let's say you're five deal
breakers he has three three of the five
let's tell you five things you want
here's three
I'm not gonna lie but he doesn't cheat
I'm taking the cheetah because let me
tell you one thing yeah that's very
intense
most girls would most girls would yeah
only because I can't give that guy that
has those what like what I would give to
someone who has everything I need would
you kind of look the other way I'd be
like I didn't see it
was that easy
in my head I like to say out loud I
would take the free but if he cheated
subtly and didn't embarrass me yeah
if there were no public embarrassment
and he cheated very subtly yeah
you already be inside [__] like of
course
do you know what it is it's not a public
team no me and my man as a woman we
already go through menstrual cycle going
to work having to look good and it's not
even just looking good for men some
people do that personally I don't I love
fashion I just love to feel good Within
Myself in it that being a woman is a lot
yeah I have to say life is crazy life is
easy life is no life is easy when we're
skinny people looking pretty that's what
I would say woman as a Young Man life is
harder
it's always right 100 100 that's a goal
as long as you're pretty
we're speaking of each other let's not
let's not do that as a man if you're not
successful talk tier you need to be
multiple things multiple as a woman if
you're just pretty that can just run
that can run you don't need this you
don't need to be a woman and successful
obviously don't get me wrong there's
always the reason why I say that the
reason why you're actually correct
because a man that's got a man who is
successful right a man who is a
multi-millionaire had to go through
Blood Sweat and Tears and hard work
consistently to become a millionaire you
can be 22 and pretty and and a Instagram
model and that man can go into your DMs
and say look and I'm in Dubai and I've
got a yacht right I'll fly you over and
that he can have 12 women on his yacht
yeah right who are dancing and having a
great time and those women are literally
on on benefits in the UK right but
Batman has had to Toil and work and
Blood Sweat and Tears and women are
trying to say women you you don't
understand you live life on Easy Street
you know you don't understand you live
like men if you find a successful man
trust me that manners had to go through
the hell to become successful you can
you can actually be next to a successful
man and not have done much
my point is
as a man as you or me
that
that party time it's not going to be
forever exactly we settle my fair enough
we settle can I add something and then
uh like from my own experience I came to
this country when I was younger right
from where from Senegal okay uh I did
I've did a lot of stuff right I've I've
did crazy stuff but when it was time for
me to get married I went back home with
Senegal I went back to Senegal yeah I
found the right woman for me because I
knew what I saw from what I saw in this
country there's no chance for the women
in this country for the women in this
country there was no you wouldn't marry
a woman no country no oh there's there's
one percent chance right okay because
I'm not saying every woman that I meet
in the city on Friday night or Saturday
night all the same yeah
no no no
we man we we look forward to that
settlement okay and for us a settlement
is getting married finding the right
woman and having children and having
children and settle yes right yeah for
for women their beauty
the older you get it it goes down it
goes down yeah yeah and as it goes down
it's harder for you to settle yes yeah
yeah it's harder for you to settle it's
time she's she's on a big time now the
other thing is but the thing is at the
peak time is when you should be trying
to settle exactly and that's the thing
about a lot of women of this they don't
realize they don't realize
they want to do City Girl stuff and then
when they get to 30 they say oh oh my
God like what the hell am I doing woman
because
I did want to ask you bro
um did you feel like you were simping
for girls in London which is why you had
to go to Senegal no no no the reason the
reason the reason why I went back is
because it's because one it's because
one I didn't I I I don't trust the girls
I see here raising my kids
because I have seen women
I've seen girls sniffing out like in
front of the kids
I don't think you can't find a wife in
this country but it's about the odds
it's about the nature see if you're in
this country it'll be at odds you might
have to go through 50 girls to find one
that you could potentially marry I feel
like in your country because the culture
is different you probably have to only
go through five girls to find yeah but I
think it's when we're talking about Sin
pin right yeah the thing is with women
in the western world and women in the
Western World they seem like they want
guys to sim do you know wait wait they
want guys to simp for them okay so what
happens is when a man simps for a woman
right it puts him in the feminine and it
puts a woman in her masculine yeah and
so what what happens is is that the man
starts to be a woman and a woman starts
us to be a man and so what happened and
and so I'm just saying and so what
happens is is that the the Dynamics of
the relationship get skewed and so women
while they may lack because women
generally lack attention you're women
you lack attention right however too
much attention from a simp you ain't
gonna respect him as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible